Rotten Tomatoes folks have ranked the
films that were best buy the tomato
meter and they put a lot of factors not
just the score so if you look on the
rankings the score isn't the only thing
it's also how many times was it reviewed
what was the critical consensus within
the reviews that critical counts for and
these are the top films and get out is
number one and get out be number one is
a tribute to diversity in Hollywood cuz
look what number two is and now you have
not only interracial dating you're gonna
be so mad but like there's a lot in
these movies that should tell Hollywood
not only are they great they're
profitable so Jordan would get out and
Camille and Emily with the big six
these were screenplays that they had
been working on for a long time let's
also talk about a third of these movies
being Disney movies the House of mouse
is dominating yeah but also lady bird
and baby driver also you know there's
rider directors you know Edgar Wright
this was another film that he had in his
brain for a long period of time he
wanted to do an action movie set to
music if you look at the list how many
of them are action movies for action
movie baby driver star wars the last
Jedi Logan Wonder Woman even Dunkirk
action movies are dominating okay let's
see how 2017 compares to 2016 by the
tomato meter numbers well my favorite
movie 2016 is moonlight which is on the
2016 list yeah no look moonlight was not
one of my favorite movie
I just know people that actually live it
so to me it wasn't that avant-garde it
wasn't shocking but what we see
Jacqueline with 2016 and 2017 is that
diversity is at the top we are leading
the way in diversity and Hollywood is
following along and I love to see that
this year was a year of surprises last
year was a new year surprises I think
probably maybe two of the films on there
where you could say they were a really
big surprise we'll probably arrival in
hell or high water but again look at the
power of Disney they're half the list
this year I feel 2017 the thing that I
think rose to the top are independent
new fresh stories and if you look at
2016 there was a lot of reboots there
was a lot of stuff that we'd already
kind of seen before like I feel like
we're getting new stories that's what
was good let's look at what wasn't so
good it was kind of a mixed bag with a
lot of films but will we get to the
worst I mean it's real
and topping the list is just getting
started with Morgan Freeman at 5% on the
tomato meter and it's almost like a
straight-to-dvd effort see these are
cash grabs like this is Morgan Freeman
getting a check agree to disagree babe
you'll agree the 2017 it was also a low
year for box office receipts yeah at
least two of the films on this list did
fairly well at the box office if you've
got kids then you're gonna go to the
emoji movie cuz it's cute then have to
entertain you or stimulate you made a
boatload of money but Tyler Perry you
know your people are gonna make Tyler
Perry's money back every first weekend
but put the worst of 2017 next to the
worst of 2016 I mean I think this right
here just doesn't say oh the 2016 movies
average where's the 27 it's not even be
close but London is fallen Batman versus
Superman and My Big Fat Greek Wedding -
all made money at the box office well
that's the best and worst of 2017 by the
tomato meter what do you guys think does
their movies like girls trip that I
think should be on there there's three
billboards in every Missouri which I
absolutely love and recommend to
everybody that's not on this list but
get out the big sick I'm happy that both
of them are at the top again it
highlights diversity come on Hollywood
give me more of that
but the thing I think is really funny on
here is the almost perfect because we
have two films on here both of them had
one critic who voted them rotten and
those are the ones it's kind of crazy
that they were almost perfect and they
just barely missed it who's that
curmudgeon
no I'm not gonna talk the critic but I
will say this is the fact that the
internet knows who these people you can
find out but I do think it's really
funny that we have two writer directors
that had their own stories that they'd
worked on for a long time and just for
one person they would be sitting at both
hundred-percent of here